but i'll tell you
as i said the polls are shifting
shifting in pretty good ways right
and one of the biggest things that we're
seeing happening
is that people are flocking away from
donald trump as a result
of this january 6 you know the televised
hearings and everything
and one of the people
who is watching this happening
and seeing
how republicans are reacting
happens to be republican pollster frank
luntz
now frank luntz appeared on cnn
yesterday
and on cnn he was actually asked about
an issue i talked about yesterday ron
desantis beating donald trump in that
new new hampshire poll
and here
is what mr luntz had to say about that
when asked if desantis is a threat to
trump he said quote
it's more than a threat
the governor is proving that his
approach and what he's trying to
accomplish and what he has accomplished
in florida is more significant and
republicans are now saying
it's time to move on
there's now polling out that shows that
donald trump is actually paying a price
for what these hearings
are showing
now
saying that the republican party is
ready to move on from donald trump based
on one poll from university in new
hampshire with just a few hundred people
in i don't know that i'm willing to say
that hey donald trump's out of the party
everybody's moving on that's reading way
too much into a single way too early
poll
however he's not wrong
about the other polls
here's one of my favorite things
prior to that very first televised
hearing two-thirds of people in this
country did not believe that donald
trump bore responsibility for what
happened on january 6th today
two-thirds of people in this country
believe that donald trump bears
responsibility for what happened on
january 6th
it literally flipped
it flipped
in two weeks folks
two
weeks that's pretty impressive right
and that's the point
like that's how powerful these hearings
are
that's why all of this
matters
not just because we want to change
public opinion mostly obviously because
we want
justice
we want those people who broke the law
to pay the price
but i think we're all kidding ourselves
if we don't admit to at least a small
degree that there is some level of
vengeance in us that feels good about
this that wants it to tank his approval
rating which it has his approval rating
donald trump's has gone down since these
committee hearings began
that is of course what frank luntz is
referring to
people are tying donald trump directly
to this and as i said you've got
republican candidates dr oz is a great
one they're running away from him even
though trump came out and backed him
made him
you know had it not been for trump oz
probably wouldn't have won that primary
same thing with jd vance
i don't know if jd vance is running away
from the trump messaging
but other people are more and more
candidates
and it's not because
donald trump is still not an influential
figure in the party he is and he will
remain
an influential figure in the party
whether they want him to or not he's
there to stay he's your
monster
you get to keep him forever
but the voters out there
they're not so happy with it
and we're going to start to see i
promise you in the coming weeks we're
going to see more and more republicans
start to run away from him
because like lunt said
it's having a real impact on donald
trump it may not be affecting the rest
of the republican party
these hearings at least
but if they continue to try to tie
themselves to trump
it will come back to hurt them in the
midterms
we need to take another quick break i'm
farron cousins from ring of fire sitting
in for david pakman and we'll be right
back with more i think this is the
biggest discount that any sponsor has
ever offered on the david pakman show
this is crush organics crush organics
loves the show so much
they're giving my viewers 50 off their
entire collection of organic cbd
products when you use the code pacman
i'm the only show
where you can get this big a discount
that i like and for each sale crush
organics will donate ten dollars to the
last prisoner project that's a really
great non-profit helps to
free non-violent drug offenders and
reform drug laws very important and it
doesn't stop there anyone who uses my
code also gets a free jar
of cbd gummies or a jar of cbd topical
cream crush has only the best organic
cbd whether you're looking for oils
creams or edibles so that's 50 percent
off and a free jar of gummies or topical
cream and 10 bucks towards creating real
change in our justice system go to crush
organics dot u s
and use the code pacman the link is down
below